Well, Happy New Year Church. Welcome to
2023 and this Gathering of
Henderson Hills Baptist Church.
My coach used to say when we were watching film
in the dark late and early and all
that. He says it he'd rather have you standing than sleeping? So
if you stayed up too late last night, feel free to go to
the edges or the back and stand up to stay awake. I get that Rob.
So if you're new to our church, we're grateful
that you're here. We're thankful that we
get to have such a joyous occasion to
celebrate kick off a new year. We want to get to know you. Maybe you're
coming off a Christmas Eve and you're here and maybe you're trying to
start a new Rhythm this year. However that looks for you either
way. We want to know you and help you. However, we
can there's a QR code and seat in front of you or just come talk to one
of us today the big desk out there one of us up here. We'd
love to just to meet you and get to know you that way
but as we look ahead and look at all the
unknowns and all the uncertainties and all the possibilities of
a new year ahead of us. I have this small slip of
paper here. It's torn off of a larger sheet, of course,
and I don't remember the whole context of why I wrote or what paper
On this all of that but it sits on my desk.
It's right underneath my monitor. I see it all the time when I'm writing sermons
and you're gonna see a picture of it because you can't see this of course,
but I've talked about this before over the last couple years, but
here's what it says in my chicken scratch handwriting
here on it. I wrote in pencil it
says a question.
It says when will we get desperate for
him?
When will we get desperate for him?
Speaking for myself. It was like, when will I
stop being so self-reliant?
And in fact, there's a word underneath it. The word
is broken.
That's the idea behind whatever I was
writing this meeting in. I don't know what it was. But
but I know the date because up in the
top right corner, very small up there. I dated it.
And it's three ten twenty twenty.
Little did I know what was coming the very next day
March 11th of 2020 which
was the night the Thunder game got derailed because
one of the opposing players got covid and they began to postpone
everything and and all the cancellations began to happen
including that weekend for our church where
we hadn't been online at all, but then we go completely online
for two and a half months.
We were affected by it as well. Now wherever
you stand in all those issues I get there's debate in
that but
but no one can deny that the day after
me asking the question of myself. When
will we get desperate for him?
Our Lives fundamentally changed because of
covid
it's like God was stripping away everything
that we had been relying on.
like
finances jobs entertainment
Comforts God was stripping it all away
and was revealing our need for
him.
He did it even more deeply in me personally.
A year later when I was dealing with crippling vertigo for
a couple months and even at that moment for
that stretch wondering if I'm ever going to be able to function again.
But God does that.
at times in our lives
He might use nature.
or sorrow
or other common occurrences in our lives to shake us
up.
to awaken us from our spiritual stupor
to challenge and confront our laziness. He brings
things or allows things into our lives.
Yet as we'll see today. He does it all.
to draw us nearer to him
Any of it all of it is to draw us nearer and
closer to him.
Because we were made to be dependent on him.
We so often forget that and we we
start to to think we're self-made that
we can handle it. All we can do what we need to do. We can make this thing happen.
We forget that we were made to be dependent on
him.
And that's who we want to be.
Around here as a church as individuals as families, we want to be dependent
like that. In fact, one of our churches values
the things that we hold tightly to is called
desperate dependence.
And it's from that season like it. It's directly tied in
my brain and in our hearts as Elders back to covid and
in my vertigo, it's tied to that
desperate dependence where instead of thinking that we can
do it all ourselves like our programs and
our skills. We put it all in the right formula It's Gonna Change
lives. No the way we say it is we rely on
the Holy Spirit to empower our lives and our church
as we humbly abide in Jesus recognizing we
can do nothing apart from him.
That's one of our core values.
Which is why we felt led to start 2023.
With this that we're kind of loosely calling a solemn
assembly today.
Realigning our hearts to God's
ways and expressing our dependence upon him.
Where we're not just going to talk about it. We're going to
practice that we're gonna actually do some things and hopefully get us to
that.
Desperate dependence leads us to today but it's also why we're starting off
the week of 2020 this first week of 2023 with
what we're calling a week of prayer very creatively, but
but a week of prayer.
Where we're going to be praying separately on our own
of course, but then also a couple times together.
Depending on the Lord.
Gathering to say God we need you we can do
nothing apart from you and I'll explain more about both today
and this week as we go forward, but we need to see
it in God's word. And so take your copy of God's word. Turn with me to the
Book of Joel.
We're going to be today in Joel chapter 2.
Joel is in the Old Testament really if you were here
the fall we were in Micah just a few pages left from there.
You'll find the Book of Joel short
little book there.
now as you turn there, I'm not going to do a deep dive into the overall of
Joel today because
at the beginning of my regularly scheduled sabbatical coming up
in April Heath Thomas is going to come and
he is going to he's an expert on the prophets which
Joel's a profit. He's an expert he's going to do a deep dive
into the Book of Joel for the first five weeks of my
sabbatical where he's gonna preach through this whole book
so you can look forward to that. We're just going to touch on it a
little bit today and for our purposes what we need to understand.
About Joel he was a prophet
similar to Micah. He spoke on behalf of God to his
people.
And in all the prophets there were warnings of judgment to
come as they turned away from God, but there
were also Promises of restoration if they
returned to God that's in every one of the prophets. You see that
back and forth.
But Joel's context specifically.
Was he was saying what he's saying here in the Book of Joel immediately
after God had sent a
swarm of locusts.
to judge his people
Now we might only know the word Locust from like Charlton
Heston 10 commandments the plague
it's one of the plagues.
Kids, here's a way to think about it like bugs life the enemy grasshoppers.
That's kind of what a locust is. And so think look like
they're gonna eat stuff and that's what they did. God sent this swarm Army
of locusts and they ate everything all
the trees grain Vineyards. All of
it was gone, which means they had no food and they had no prospects of
food.
That was the Judgment God brought on his people. They had
turned away from him to follow these false gods
and they had sinful thoughts and actions and
so God disciplined his people.
Yet.
through Joel
God offered the promise of restoration if
they would return to him.
If they turned back, but but he he offers that
yet still through Joel. He says actually there's
a worse disaster coming. There's
total Destruction coming if you continue down this path, I'm
gonna send an army not of locust but of people to completely
destroy your land.
And eventually we see in the history. That's what
happened.
But for this opportunity this moment in time
for Judah they had the opportunity to see
which way they were going to go.
Now here's what we can't do with this. I said this back with Micah we
can't make a one-to-one comparison here.
With with God blessing our land like this.
So if we if we return to the Lord as his people God's
Gonna Bless America, no that it's not the same because we're not
a Theocratic nation state living in God's
Promised Land like they were
so this is not the kingdom here. So if we
repent God's not necessarily going to bless our land,
but what we do need to see here.
This is what Joel's instructive for us.
We need to see why God was saying this
to his people.
Why was God doing the things here and saying these
things to his people and how were they supposed to
respond to it?
Because the one thing we can relate to is being God's people
as Christians.
How should we respond to what God says here and
seeing that will lead us then
to think more christianly about events in
the world events in our lives.
As we lift our eyes to the Sovereign god of the
universe.
And so we'll see here. Look now at Joel 2
starting in verse 12 down through verse 17.
That's big number two little number 12 underneath that and we're going
to see what God Said to his people how they were to respond as
we reflect on our response to the things in
our lives today.
Yet even now declares the Lord.
Return to me with all your heart.
With fasting with weeping and with Mourning.
And rind or tear your hearts and not your
garments.
Return to the Lord your God for his gracious and merciful slow
to anger abounding in steadfast
love.
And he relents over disaster.
Who knows whether he will not turn and relent and leave a blessing behind him
a grain offering and a drink offering for the Lord your God.
Blow the trumpet in Zion consecrate a fast
call a solemn assembly.
Gather the people consecrate the congregation assemble.
The elders gathered the children even nursing
infants.
Let the bridegroom leave his room let the bride leave
her chamber.
between the vestibule and the altar let the priests the Ministers of
the Lord weep and say
spare your people O Lord
and make not your heritage a reproach a byword
among the Nations.
Why should they say among the peoples? Where is
their God?
Lord help us understand
help us to see what you want us to see that our
eyes are ears. Our hearts would be open to be good soil for
the
The seed of your word the seed of the Gospel to
plant and bear good fruit help us to see it. Holy
spirit Empower us to respond as you
want us to respond For Your Glory.
In Jesus name amen.
So I've already kind of alluded to this but the first point that the disaster that
we would experience should first summon us
to the Lord.
That's the point we see here is that they've experienced this
utter disaster?
The Locust eating everything watched their first
response. It should be to summon to the Lord to
come to the Lord this Gathering of people.
We see here right similar to what we're doing today. It was all
the people it was older to younger. It was Elders. It
was babies. It was everybody. That's how serious this
was because of the things that had been happening.
They called it a solemn assembly a heavy
weighted Gathering of people. Like there was
a seriousness to this thing. It wasn't just a party. It was
something they took serious and Joel here.
He piles up the imperatives to emphasize the
urgency of this situation.
Even to the point where he tells a bride
and a groom that they better leave their wedding so that they come
like that's that's a big deal. Go tell the bride at
that wedding. You're coming to next week, right? Hey, you need to stop and
you need to go to church right? Like that's not gonna work.
But that's how serious this was.
And notice why in verse 12,
God said he wanted his people back.
They had turned away from him. They turned away from his Covenant
Love. They had wandered walked their own way. And
so he says return to me.
Even now he says there's a urgency to the
verse 12 like even now don't wait. Don't wait
till next week. Don't wait till you get married now return to
me.
see our natural response
may be to run away from the Lord when things are hard.
To question his goodness.
To run and try to hide from him. You've seen
it. We've all done this our kids all the time when
you were a kid, right you you know, you did something wrong.
You're a natural reaction wasn't probably to go. Tell your parents.
Hey, I broke the vase right like it. Wasn't that you
ran and hit.
Because you were afraid of what could happen the authority figure
you didn't want to confront that and so that's not natural to
us. But but what God wants for
us. It's for us to draw near to him
in that he wants us to pull to him because
he draws near he draws
near to us.
He says he draws near Psalm 34 to the Brokenhearted.
When we're broken over something in our lives, he draws near to
that and so I want you to hear this today, whatever you feel.
Whatever you carried the weight of 2022 into this year
and you're looking ahead with with Dread not with excitement and
you're feeling like man this whole thing's a
mess right now. Whatever you feel he wants
you close.
He doesn't want you to drift. He doesn't want you to walk away to doubt. He
wants you close. He wants you to draw near and Pull near.
No matter what your facing.
But I keep talking about this disaster.
What's that even mean? Like what does that word? Well, it's
the Hebrew word Raha which actually means evil
in some cases, but here it means
calamity.
adversity
hardship, we might say
now as I say that you might not be
thinking that you are going through a disaster right now.
Like you look at this and you think well, certainly not the level
of locust eating everything like for Judah. I'm not going through it.
Like that's pretty good right now life's pretty smooth sailing.
I think everything is great.
The problem with that is is I know this in my life and
you as well like in that that moment those seasons
of life, we default to self-sufficiency really
quickly, don't we?
Everything's good.
I don't really need God. I got this dangerous place
to be right.
But here's what we need to see any hardship.
Whether you perceive it to be large or small, you know, it's like these massive things
disasters like this or or even small things
any any speed bump hiccup anything
that chinks the armor in our lives and cause us
to step back and think a little bit any of those hardships
should be seen as a prompt to
draw near to the Lord.
It should be just this trigger.
like, oh I'm reminded again to draw
near to pull towards him not to run away not
to drift away but to be pulling near and now
this adversity we're talking about this disaster can be
just because we live in a fallen world.
Just because we live in this broken place.
It's not the way it's supposed to be in you might say it this way things that
aren't your fault their quotes, right?
This is this is stuff that happens when the virus
comes or a war happens or or someone else does
something to you, right? That's that's adversity in
your life that you had really nothing to do with and it just
happens to you because of sin in the world.
It can be that kind of adversity lose a job. You see these sorts
of things.
Trip us up.
But there can be other adversity that will come in your life because
of your own sinful decisions and actions.
You reap what you sow you pay the consequence.
for sinning
for walking down this road. That's not God ordained and
you pay the price and you experience hardship in
your life and it's adversity.
Yes, it happens.
Our first reaction to either of those but especially
the second one should not be like Adam and
Eve in the garden.
Where we try to hide from God and run away from
him.
We should instead draw near to him not like the little kid running
away from mom like you draw near to him, but
that's the shift we have to make because that's not natural
to us.
Here's the only way that's going to work.
The only way you could ever Pull near to God like to
the authority to run to mom when you break the vase instead of
running away. The only way you can do that is because of his character.
Did you see it in verse 13?
Return to the like sin. It's remember who he's
talking to here.
He's talking to people who have worshiped Idols sacrifice
to these false gods done all kinds
of evil stuff. He says return to
the Lord your God come back.
Don't clean yourself up before you come just come.
Because that word for means because
he is gracious.
and merciful
slow to anger abounding instead
fast, love.
I was thinking about the the parable of the Prodigal Son.
God's the father in that right? The parable is
not necessarily about the sons.
The parable is about the father in his heart first and
foremost.
because the father
No, remember he saw him coming from a long
way off.
Which means he was watching for him to come
back which means he was sitting there ready?
Ready?
For that sun to come back.
anticipating him coming back
And so that's the heart of the father. But but you have to think now
about the sun think about that son who goes to a far-off
country wastes all of his fathers inheritance. He
spins it on all kinds of sinful junk like this whole
scene would be right. He's wasted it
all he's lost it all.
The only way he's going to come back.
Is because he knows his father's good.
He has every reason to stay and to run away and stay
lost and to be out there and and yet he
comes back because he knows his father is
good and has his good for him. Now. He doesn't believe he's
going to accept him, right?
But he still says I that's my best option.
And so he comes back and the father runs to him and Embraces him
and brings him in kills the fatted calf the whole party all of
that.
He only comes back. You will only run to
God when you sin if you see him
as gracious and merciful slow to
anger and abounding in love for you.
You've got to see that.
But then you have to think. Okay. Well.
All right. I got that.
I need to come back.
how
how could I ever come back?
How should we come back? How do we when we recognize that we
have drifted?
When we have gotten complacent we've forgotten
that he is our first love that
he's priority number one, and we've we've made everything else. How do
we come back?
How should we come back? Well first clearly we
see it here repent.
repent
that's the image we get here from verse 12. God says return to
him.
with all your heart
with weeping
Mourning
He says rind or tear your hearts, not your
garments.
Now like what does that even mean? Why are we ripping clothes? Well back
then.
There was when there was extreme grief over something.
They would often symbolically tear their
clothes like literally taking their shirt and ripping it and
all open.
They would tear their clothes. They would cry out in anguish. They would
even throw ashes on their head at times all because they
were showing Brokenness.
But notice God says here. He doesn't just want an external display
of supposed repentance because
anybody can tear your clothes like you can throw ashes
on your head and you can do everything you're supposed to do and your heart
is completely Wicked.
What he says here is he wants our hearts?
He wants inward change before external change.
Because their their sin had caused such deep separation
from God it had brought separation from him. It
had brought disaster on their land. And so God says you better
grieve that you should grieve your sin.
I wonder have you ever felt.
that kind of weight
over your own sinful actions
like have you ever felt?
So horribly about your sin
that it almost makes you sick physically.
Or or weeping you're crying
because of what you've done not because of the effects or the consequences,
but because you have sinned against God.
That's what he says. You should feel we should feel.
Because that hurt was to be so profound their hearts changed.
Because that's where true transformation lies, right?
Anybody can modify behavior for a little while?
You can teach a wild animal how to do certain things
if you give enough treats.
You can you can manage Behavior you can do enough for
a while, but true transformation lasting
change.
Comes from what second Corinthians 7:10 calls Godly grief.
Different than worldly grief, it's Godly grief. Not
just apologizing to God.
It's true deep grief over sin.
Because how many times we've all had this we've all done it probably you do
something. You say I'm sorry.
And you do it again.
Sorry do it again. Sorry do it again and it's hundreds of
those right?
Is that sorry really genuine?
Not really, right. So so what we're talking about is
this true sorrow over sin. That's what produces Earnest
action because we're not just talking about sorrow. We're talking
about steps.
There's action to it.
I read somebody say it this way like it's one thing
to get woken up at 5 am.
It's a whole other thing to get out of bed at 5 am.
Right, you understand that like you get woken to me like yeah, I did
mess up.
Right. No you get up and do something about
it. That's what we're talking about with repentance.
That's what God's discipline is meant to bring in our lives.
That we awaken to where our sin is leading us where we repent from
that we turn from it and we change.
And that's that's primarily for whenever the disaster in your life is because
your own doing your own sin, which is majority. But
even if the disaster were experiencing is not
Directly tied to our own sin.
It's crisis in the world. It's something happening to you. Even
if it's not your fault, so to speak God
still wants to use it to refocus our hearts.
Crisis reveals stuff it just it just puts
you in different place. You look at it from a different angle all the sudden and it
shows you something shows you weak points. It
gives you the opportunity to pray what Psalm 139:23
and 24 says search me.
Oh God and know my heart.
Try me know my thoughts see if
there's any Grievous way in me and Lead Me in the way Everlasting.
What a great prayer, right and listen, all you wonder
if God answers prayers. He'll answer that prayer.
And whatever he shows you then you lay before him and repentance.
Knowing he's gonna forgive you.
Remember the character of God.
He's gracious and merciful slow to anger abounding in
love. He's he's proven that here this proven that
in Jesus taking the final
disaster the worst disaster death. He's
taken that on the cross paid for it and defeated
it. So what fear do we have to bring
these things before him now?
We should come with joy.
I've blown it. I've walked away. I've been
selfish. I've been prideful God take this
away from me. I know you already have forgiven me for it.
Change me make me different because I want fellowship with
you. I want Purity in my life. I want to be a
good example of Christ likeness to the world around me. God
changed me. We should do that with joy not running
away and hiding.
Bring your stuff to him bring the sin to him
and he will forgive you.
So he brings us to him in these disaster like
moments to repent first and foremost.
But he adds a couple things in this summons in verse 12.
He says that we should respond with fasting.
to these calamities
we respond we draw near to the
Lord in fasting.
Now here's what we often do with fasting in our day.
We don't talk about a whole lot. We don't do it a lot.
but what it can turn into is some kind of like spiritual Eagle
Scout award that only the super serious
Christians do and everybody else is like lower level lower
class like you if you're serious about you you fast or
you fast man you are serious about
Don't forget that Jesus said nobody's supposed to know you're doing
it.
So don't use it. It's like a spiritual badge of honor that
you are a fasting person. Like that's that's missing the
point.
But it's clearly important here in Joel.
And it's all over the Old Testament that God's people fasted when
they felt desperate before the Lord.
And notice this was a public fast
a call for a public fast. There
was many others all throughout they're even days of
the year that they would fast. So they so we're not saying that you
can't ever talk about the fasting.
What Jesus was saying is that you don't walk around looking
like you're more spiritual by the way, you're so
tired and hungry because you're fasting no he's
saying just live your life normally, but he doesn't say you
can't fast together because of desperation before
the Lord.
People fasted when they were in trouble and they recognized their
Drift from the Lord individually, but then the group as a
whole the nation would come together. It's even when they needed direction
from the Lord.
Which is picked up in the New Testament by the way, Jesus.
And the early church leadership asking God
for direction and who should go they fasted and
they prayed and they set apart Paul and Barnabas.
So this is part of it.
It shows desperation. It shows dependence asking
God even if it's not directly tied to your own sin. It's still
an expression of desperate dependence.
That we're trying to be about around here.
so
we are calling for a fast.
Friday
At least from lunch.
But there's no formula. There's no like fixed way
to do this. So if it's modified for you medically or
something else that you see would be more helpful like
just whatever.
but at least
Friday lunch for some who would choose to do that.
Take that time. You'd normally be a normal human
function of eating you take that time and set it aside
for prayer and for devotion focus on the Lord.
that as you feel the physical hunger
it reminds you of the spiritual hunger that's always there.
That we mask with so many other things.
And so we're gonna do that separately. Of
course as we're walking through life and if
you're able then one way we're going to gather at that time. Is
that on Facebook or Facebook page for
our church at noon Joe and I are going to be live streaming
a time of prayer and praise because often fasting
is tied with prayer very directly.
And it's a corporate thing. We can't all gather at noon
together. And so we're going to do it on Facebook. It's kind
of like what we did back in the early days the pandemic midday 20s,
we would live stream those interactive with people praying
through some things on our Facebook page. We're going to do something like that
again just to focus our hearts and Minds
on seeking God that Friday.
But let me just challenge you beyond Friday.
That's one thing and we can do that. Okay, great, but
But beyond that consider how to draw near to
the Lord yourself personally.
Like regularly making this a rhythm somehow using
fasting in your life to just expose your own
heart and to express your dependence on God figure out ways
to make that happen.
It's one way not the only way it's one way to
draw near.
There's one more though here in Joel 2 of this invitation
to return one more action. It's what
the whole next week's going to be centered on. It's prayer.
repent fast pray
They are summoned here to pray.
It's all over what is said to the people in 12
13 14. It's explicit in verse
17 for the priests as they stand between the vestibule and the
alter meaning in the temple grounds kind of as a go between within
people and God they were to pray that God
would relent. They it's kind of like Moses for the people and exodus this
this kind of idea, but it's all about prayer where
they're crying out to the Lord to change their
situation to overcome their enemies to fix their
hearts to bless them again.
Notice, this is a prayer not just for their needs prayer
for the problems in their life the pains
and their legs, right? It's not just prayer for that. It's broken dependence
on the lord. It's desperate dependence
for God to move.
But that's what a crisis does right.
Think about how your prayers change when you get that phone call from
the doctor.
Like that morning list, you're praying for this this this this you get
the phone call from doctor. It's a whole different ballgame.
And you are diving in you're a focused and you're one one
track.
dependence on the Lord
It's not just for your own Comfort anymore. It's for this when you're when your
family member struggles or when this happens you you start praying
differently. It's why the church in Acts
was devoted to prayer.
Because they felt the crisis they felt the threat of
people potentially coming after them to kill them.
Church in Acts also understood that the task Jesus
left for them was so far
beyond themselves. There's no way they could do with him.
They needed him like God you tell us we're gonna go to the ends of
the Earth with this thing.
We don't even know like 20 miles out from here
and you're telling us the ends of the Earth.
God you got to do this.
There's no way we can do this on our
God you have to work.
David Platt said that the early church.
For there for them the early church prayer was
fundamental.
Well today in our churches. We've made it supplemental.
We can do this. We got it. Oh, yeah, God, could you bless our plans,
please?
God
we finally hit the end of our rope. Can you take care of this
for us?
So here in a moment, we're going to pray.
with that in mind
But also during this week of prayer.
You can see it on your notes or in the app. If you're using that
their prayer Points each day to pray for.
We'll put social media posts up about them every day. You'll get
it maybe even got one this morning from us. If you have the app about
a notification to pray today for certain things right get
one every day this week.
And this is just as a way for all of us to knock on the door of Heaven asking God
to do what only he can do.
depending on him for him to move for him
to do things only he can take the credit for
and so we're gonna pray separately. We're gonna focus our hearts devote ourselves
to prayer but also,
on Wednesday morning
6 am
down in student room one which is down the hallway that direction there's
entrances around it.
We're going to be gathering again to pray.
At our church in Fort Worth. We had refugees that were from the
middle of Africa. We have Afghan refugees here, and we have a few others, but
but from like the Congo area Burundi they
ended up in Fort Worth.
And they showed up and one of them was a church planter.
And we were talking in first week. They were there. He's like oh so so
when do you pray?
Like as a church I said, well, you know, we're we're making a
step forward in our time of gathering and we're praying and services more than
we do and and we're trying to as Elders pray better
and he's like no. No, when do you pray?
It's like what do you mean? It's like no one's your prayer meeting.
I said well we don't have one.
He said well.
And he started laying out that they would meet multiple times
a week.
To pray just not not preaching not singing nothing just
to devote to the Lord.
And we wonder why God is moving in such immense ways
around the world other places.
Planting churches. He planted two churches in his home country
five churches in refugee camp.
Like okay gosh.
supplemental right
So we're going to gather we're going to pray Focus time.
Because we want God to do what only he can take the credit for.
We don't want to do what things that we can do that by
our skill and our ability our money we can make
happen.
It's not what we want.
We want God to do what only he can take because then
he gets the glory for it not us.
If you can't make it at 6am on Wednesday pray, we are if you
can only make it for 20 minutes of it come for 20 minutes. If you only make it for 40 or
10, whatever just be praying that God
would move.
But again this notice Joel 2 was the
people's response to disaster.
God called them to return back to him and they
showed their heart changed through repentance through fasting through
prayer.
And notice verse 14. They didn't know if God was going to change the situation
or not.
Who knows whether God's gonna turn a who knows whether this
cut this enemy nation's gonna take us over. We don't know if God's
Gonna spare us from that. We don't know.
We don't know either.
You don't know.
Well, God, take away that cancer. Well God fix that marriage. We don't know.
We pray that he will we pray in faith that he will.
But only God knows his Sovereign plan.
But because we do know that he loves us.
That he has good in store for his children who love him
and are called according to his purpose then that means we can surrender to
him and to his plan.
following him expressing dependence on him
in Practical real ways
That's what this is all about.
But here's a sad thing that I know happens in my heart.
when I face hardships
Maybe this happens to you as well.
when something comes up
triggering that hardship that speed bump that crisis that
disaster whatever it is.
I get really myopic and what I mean by that
is tunnel vision.
Like you're looking through a tube and it's one thing. That's all
it is that one issue that one crisis. It's
all about everything about that.
And you completely forget everything else around you
it becomes all about that.
And so yes.
Yes disasters meant to draw us back to the
Lord but hardship and struggle should
also direct us to the Future.
Like it's so easy to get locked in and forget everything
else including what's coming. We cannot
forget what's coming as well.
Did you see the end of verse 17 here?
That because of what Judah was going through other people
and other nations were doubting whether Yahweh was even real.
Right. Did you see that? Where is there God?
Has God not abandoned them. I mean they say they believe
in this Yahweh who provides for them, but is he even real I mean
look at they just got all these locusts eaten everything.
They become a byword which means like a laughing stock.
Is God even real?
Isn't it true that when you are going through the fire?
You might be tempted to think the same
thing.
God are you really good?
God look at what I'm going through. Are you even there?
I don't feel you.
All I feel is Carnage and pain.
It looks like you're not in control.
That's why we cannot forget our Eternal perspective.
See even in the Book of Joel in most of the prophets. There's this look to the
Future.
It's to this day of the Lord they call it.
It's to where God is going to judge his enemies fully
and finally and he's going to bless his people fully and finally and
everything's gonna be made right the Messiah comes and full form
Kingdom on Earth all of that. It's done.
but notice Joel this was
2,500 years ago. He's looking through
that glass pretty dimly.
He's looking ahead to something he has no idea about but what
do we have the privilege of seeing we look back at this
Messiah Jesus who lived died
resurrected to guarantee that
that restoration is coming someday.
Because think about that when he came up out of the Grave alive with a
new body what it means is that those who are in him also will
one day be resurrected with a new body. No more
sickness no more death.
He's guaranteed that restoration.
Even more than that when he ascended back to Heaven that means
one day he's coming back to inaugurate his kingdom fully
and finally on Earth where he is the king. There's no
more sin. There's no more warring Nations. It's just
him and his people fully perfect.
Is guaranteed it?
So Joel is looking at this like man someday. I
hope this happens. I don't know what it looks like exactly. We still look
ahead. Yes, but we also look back to Jesus and what
he's done to guarantee all of this.
That's how
that's how job.
That's how job could say.
which by the way
I know your life is hard.
Go read job.
He experienced the worst suffering beyond anything
any of us will ever experience.
But that's that perspective that Eternal perspective is
how he could say in job 19:25 and
26. He says for I know that my redeemer
lives.
And at the last at the end, he will stand upon
the Earth.
And after my skin has been thus destroyed
which for job he got destroyed.
Yet in my flesh.
Shall see God.
This is gonna be destroyed but I'm gonna get a new body and
in that body. I'll see God who standing on the earth.
That's how job could see it.
faith
listen, I know the destruction of everything we know and love is hard when
you lose things. It's immensely difficult
and it should draw Us near to the Lord. Absolutely because
Hebrews 4:16 says let us with confidence draw
near to the throne of grace that we would
receive mercy and find Grace to help in our time of need. He
wants you to come to him for mercy and Grace
in your need.
It should draw us to him, but it should also direct our
minds to the fact that this is not
the end.
Restorations coming the kingdom is coming
on Earth as it is in heaven. We have a king who Sovereign
who is good. And that's why we can
repent differently. That's why we can fast differently. That's
why we can pray differently.
Even if we don't understand what's going on, even if we can't see through
the mess.
Psalm 27:14 says wait for
the Lord.
Wait for Yahweh. Be strong Let Your Heart Take courage.
Wait for the Lord.
So what we're going to do now.
In light of all that we've seen in Joel how God's
stirring our hearts towards this dependence on
him. We're going to enter into a time set aside consecrated
for the Lord in prayer.
So over the next few minutes the worst leaders come back out and help be
a part of this. We're going to sing. We're going to pray we're gonna do some things
as we are led by the spirit through
it. But let's just start in reflection
of what God's done here in Joel 2 how
he's applied that to our hearts.
And just ask you to Bow your heads to close your
eyes. There's nothing super spiritual about that. It's just merely to remove distractions
from our lives.
And we can just focus on the Lord and even see
in our Mind's Eye what he wants us to
see.
So just start by doing that and and quietly.
On your own just begin reflecting on what God has said
to you today.
How he wants you to respond to this.
As James says to be a doer of the word not a
hearer only.
What is he showing you?
about some things that
even walking away from him in
and holding on to your way instead of his way.
You've been looking at or participating in or
or eating or drinking those
things and
he wants you to return to him.
What is it?
Maybe even pray Psalm 139 right
now 23 and 24.
Search me o God.
know my heart
try me and know my thoughts what ask
him to show you the motivations underneath
everything.
And see if there be any Grievous way in me.
Lead Me in the way Everlasting
ask him to show you sin.
temptations that you're holding on to
and ask him to lead you in the way.
his way
until 2 said to consecrate the congregation that's an idea
of setting apart purifying.
How does he want to purify you right now?
Cleanse wash away junk that's cluttering
your pursuit of Jesus.
Take it to him.
Goodness, take it to him.
Let him forgive let him wash.
You confess your Cindy's faithful and just to forgive you and to cleanse you
from all unrighteousness.
Maybe for the first time ever or in a long time. You're feeling the
weight.
of the sin
in your life
and you just can't
can't even sit. You have to you're kind of being forced to
your knees before the Lord. That's fine.
Nothing wrong with right where you are getting out
sitting on the ground on your face
on your knees. Whatever. If you need to come to the front, it's kind
of a marker. There's nothing spiritual about this up here, but just a
marker in your own heart of a step of faith.
Don't be ashamed.
He wants you to feel the weight of it so that he can lift the
weight off in his grace.
Others of you might be feeling that disaster from the outside
Source right now.
It's nothing you did. It's
that diagnosis or
that abusive spouse or
that
job loss, or
whatever
from an outside
pressure on you and you're feeling the weight of that and
it's restricting. It's hard to follow Jesus
and pursue him.
We want to help carry that burden for you.
So we've done this.
something like this before where if you
would just be so bold if that's you if you're feeling the
weight of something that
it just so burdensome to you. It's hindering worship
hindering your faith.
I don't really believe that God's good at times I struggle to see his
goodness.
If you'd be so bold to just stand up and admit
that and say I need prayer because we
want to surround you want people to to gather around you and pray for
you in this moment. We're not going to separate all out and do the
prayer groups like we've done before but but if you'd be willing if you're in
that moment and you're like I am in the disaster life is
hard. I can't find my way. Would you
just stand up right now or raise your hand if you're unable to stand up.
and if there's a few people right around there
you kind of take a look and quickly just look and
if
There's a few that would gather around. Those people are standing. Thank
you. Thank you.
And just pray for them briefly Right Where You Are.
And just care for each other.
There's no shame.
There's no shame in admitting like Brokenness because we're
all broken.
And there's moments that we feel it more than others. But if that's you right now
again, don't don't hesitate if you if you need prayer stand up
right now or raise your hand.
if you're seeing that somewhere around there just
Gather around and pray for them even out
loud pray for them.
God I thank you for these who have
courageously admitted where they're at.
God meet them where they are.
You draw near to the Broken Heart of these have admitted and
and said even publicly that they are brokenhearted right
now for whatever reason and we pray you would draw near
to them.
They would feel your love and peace through brothers and
sisters surrounding them right now.
Thank you God.
care for them care for all of us those who
are even wanting to but didn't
stand up.
encourage God
encourage and meet needs
one thing that
we
see happen in situations and times like these in our
lives where
God kind of asks the question of us.
Will we surrender to him?
We don't like that word.
but when he's the authority King
savior who's good?
It's worth it.
We have no fear should have no fear to surrender these
situations. We're praying for anything else in our lives to him.
Remember the songs that we sing are also prayers.
So we're going to sing a song very familiar. I surrender
all.
as a prayer
so wherever you've kind of walked through the last few minutes here
God's shown you some things in your heart open your
hands to him and say Jesus I surrender all
to you.
This is what we
've been called to what we should want.
hard to do
But let's make this a prayer to him now as we sing I surrender all
together.
Oh to Jesus.
I surrender to him.
I freely.
and Trust
in his presence
I Surrender
I served oh
to
the my bless.
It's where I
served
to Jesus
surrendered his feet
worldly pleasures
all forsaken. Take
me Jesus Take.
I surrender all.
I Surrender
all to the my blessed
save your
to Jesus
surrender Lord, I give
myself to you fill
me with.
and Power
thy blessings for me
I surrender all
to thee
my blessed savior.
surrender
It's easy to say and to sing. Of course.
It's hard to do.
So we're going to be just quiet.
Process through what the Lord has showed you the last
few moments.
Of what does he want you to surrender to him?
Ask him to search you.
see where
Where you need to release something?
We're often never quiet to let that happen. So let's
just be totally quiet.
and asking the Lord to move
in our own hearts
father confirming us
not
a try harder mentality
a New Year's resolution idea today confirm in
us your goodness your kindness.
Your Love
so deeply that it compels us to action.
we take steps because
who you are is good.
Who you are is enough.
and Who We Are
in relation to who you are
Should bring us sorrow.
But joy, because you cross that boundary.
So may we respond today in this week with joy?
excitement
anticipation to repent
fast to pray
to be near you